E aí
[Música]
é obrigado a todos por estarem aqui a o
meu nome é Miguel e eu quero falar sobre
temos sobre tempo e
a expectativa
e eu quero te mostrar uma coisa
é uma coisa que
já viajou no tempo
bom então moeda eu não sei se vocês
conseguem ver é de 1882 e de certa forma
podemos dizer que viajou no tempo
depende da perspectiva mas eu gosto de
acreditar que tudo aquilo que viaja no
tempo tem mais valor no final da sua
viagem do que tinha no início
é um pouco romântico sim mas a
perspectiva é exatamente isso a
perspectiva um pouco com uma crença ou
como o ideal que nos permite ver coisas
o que a partida não existem
e nós temos do reverso da medalha
E quando podemos passar por elas
e sem que nunca tínhamos visto
o visto que não podemos perder o futuro
e nem tão-pouco alterar
e o passado
o próximo apenas Euromilhões ponto de
vista da realidade
nós temos à nossa frente Obrigado a
todos postarem aqui o meu nome é Miguel
e eu quero falar sobre tempo sobre tempo
epis
A Festiva
e eu quero te mostrar uma coisa
é uma coisa que
é mas já tivemos aqui não já
o pênis a perspectiva
E aí
é obrigado a todos por estarem aqui o
meu nome é Miguel e eu queria Estou a
brincar agora já chega já chega deste
Loop Infinito Na verdade eu agora não
sei se é possível Silvia Agora vou
deixar cair um bocadinho este clima de
ilusão e gostava de ter duas ou três
pessoas para para com quem pudesse
e aqui perguntar disso eu pode ser a tua
vir aqui Vera tudo aqui a ver o Antônio
Calheiros onde se pode ser essas pessoas
eu posso elas podem falar
e Jads e Jadson fechar os livros Ok
avião não isso não é nada de complicado
aqui eu até que nem você quer
influenciar muito até um por isso aqui a
frente assim eu não desinfluencia muito
está ocupado mas Antônio e Vera eu não
sei se vocês estão familiarizados com
baralho de cartas mas nós temos cartas
vermelho e cartas pretas isso vai no
encontro de nós temos falta de
Perspectiva da mãe não temos direção e
eu quero arranjar uma direção
autoconfiante disto também se der errado
deu errado mas eu tenho quase certeza
que não Antônio e Vera eu vou começar
pelo Antônio a cartas pretas e as cartas
vermelhas que é pretas ou vermelhas
as pedras tudo que escolher é tudo
aquilo que vamos que vamos pretas e
assim temos de pretas temos espadas e
temos de paus espadas copas e Espadas
Espadas temos cartas número Antônio
cartas figura número a figura número
número temos números de baixo nos médios
e número salta para demorar mais tempo
mas eu também não posso demorar muito
tempo mas temos de dois ou quatro temos
a cinco seis sete oito nove dez de
espadas a sua primeira vez eu até já vou
colar aqui eu não queria fazer isso aí a
maioria das pessoas coisa esta carta e
não queria que vocês fizessem esta casa
das pessoas dizem sempre a espadas dama
de copas ás de copas mas nós estamos em
espadas e em números tanto esse não é o
caso Vera
a decisão final estamos em números qual
dos números é que temos 71
As Sete Espadas vocês podem não
acreditar mas eu sabia que vocês iam
fazer essa carta será Sério Sabia fora
eu tenho
e eu tenho que posso dizer onde está Eu
acho que o Sete Espadas está
e dentro deste copas e aposento dez de
copas e o áries de hoje
não não não e não enganei-me tem que
mandar outra vez que eu fiz um
e eu não sei se você reparar Você estude
antes de pedir qualquer uma destas 52
cartas aqui mas vocês poderão os a
espada sem pedir antes que as damas de
copas que eu tentei sugerir assim início
mas o que difere esta carta todas as
outras é que todas as outras cartas são
diferentes Apesar de todas terem um
farol
e todas todas são vermelha e apenas uma
carta
a Record esperança e de uma direção que
eu acho que é podemos levar
Oi gente Obrigado a todos eu vou estar
aqui também ao meio-dia e meia e eu
convidar vocês tiverem um baralho de
cartas não são Antônio não sou a Vera
toda a gente estiver aqui se puder pegar
um baralho de cartas tenha em casa nem
precisa de estar completo e gostava de
fazer uma coisa geral quando digo geral
é para toda a gente até quem está mais
perto e não tem vídeo
o tanto obrigado e até já
E aí
[Música]